or walkouts by some Scottish teachers
which began yesterday have continued
today
tomorrow will be the first of six days
of postal strikes across December
rail strikes will take place over four
days next week with more planned for
January
and new strikes announced on Monday will
start on Christmas Eve and run until
early on the 27th
NHS workers are scheduled to walk out
for four days in December ambulance
staff on the 21st and 28th and nurses on
the 15th and 20th in England Wales and
Northern Ireland
borderfall staff became the latest to
announce industrial action with airports
affected from the 23rd of December to
the 26th and then again from the 28th to
the 31st
and driving test examiners security
staff at Eurostar and some civil
servants will also go on strike this
month Ali Fortescue reports
it's hard to list the sectors the range
of workers walking out I couldn't do my
job safely hard two to hear stories like
Katie's I'm definitely working more and
I'm being more mindful of my spending
um to make ends meet for sure I have
colleagues that are using food banks
um I have had colleagues you know tell
their children that they don't think
that Christmas is going to be a
particularly great Christmas for them
this year I actually feel in a way
fortunate that I don't have children I
have to say that too
and it's not just nurses this was a home
secretary's response today to the latest
action called by border Force we've got
plans in place that will involve uh to a
degree uh bringing in some of our
military colleagues to help us in a
variety of roles and we want to I mean
ultimately you know I'm not willing to
compromise on security at the border and
as trained workers prepare to strike two
the pm has talked about tougher
anti-strike laws to stop the whole
country grinding to a halt could we see
the government increasing the threshold
for strikes make sure that more notice
needs to be given there's plenty of
options for legislation it's something
that's been looked at for a long time
something that Boris Johnson and Liz
truss were looking at but it will take
months to work it won't keep trains
moving and sectors working in the short
term and any constructive tone between
the government and the unions last week
turned to confrontation this week do you
accept that for a lot of people you've
become the face of winter disruption
misery for a lot of people over
Christmas well our messages were really
sorry for the disruption we don't want
that to happen we don't want our members
out on strike at Christmas time we've
got a bit of sabotage going on and
that's not good enough we want Mark
Harper and the government to be a
facilitator for a settlement rather than
an obstacle to it and that's got to
change and what of Labor it's not clear
they have an answer either labor aren't
offering inflation busting pay Rises
Lisa nandy said that would be
unaffordable you're waiting for
inflation to come down like the
conservatives aren't you one of the
reasons why uh nurses NHS workers
people who work on our Railways are
taking industrial action is of course as
you say because we've got the highest
inflation in uh in 40 years and the
highest tax burden in 70 years and
energy Bills going through the roofs the
government could also be doing more to
talk the root of some of these problems
but the government has moved from
negotiation to preparation for a winter
of strike strain that will impact us all
Ali Ford SKU Sky News Westminster